thanks for the introduction and I'm
gonna spend the the topic as efficient
and resilient systems in the cognitive
era and I'm going to try and explain
what I mean by that so I have a bunch of
people to acknowledge and I'm not going
to go through that but suffice it to say
that we have excellent University
collaborators I want to acknowledge
first among them
professor Mitra who sitting in the
audience thank you for inviting me and
then a bunch of different people at IBM
a lot of what I'm going to talk about is
based on research that was funded by one
or more DARPA programs and as a result
of being the PI of such large programs
projects I have to work with researchers
from a number of different disciplines
which is very interesting and also some
of this some of the thoughts that I'm
going to present today are sponsored by
IBM Academy of Technology of which I'm a
member in the sense that they they allow
me to run workshops and stuff like that
and and file reports with executives
which which is which is kind of
important function that we have so I
view my current role as a thought leader
in other words chief philosopher it's
because at at my age you know that's all
I can do is think of new ideas and
inspire the team sometimes that works
sometimes it doesn't work and you'll see
some things but before I do I'll do
something unusual which I never do is
acknowledge some of my teachers which is
a traditional thing from the culture
that I come from but I the reason I'm
particularly interested in acknowledging
these three gentlemen is that they're
all have Stanford roots so given that
I'm giving this talk at Stanford I have
to mention professor Jacob Abraham with
whom I did my master's thesis professor
dr. Bob rau who was my PhD Co advisor
until he left Illinois
started a startup company as like many
professors do called side room and then
professor at Davidson who was my advisor
PhD advisor now let's see yeah it's true
he's he was a start-up guy and so while
at Stanford that was while he was still
at Stanford yes and I should actually
also mention Professor Michael Flynn who
was Bob's advisor and through through
him I got to work a little bit with
Professor Flynn in those days of my
doctoral work and those those very
precious those came a point when Bob
left Illinois and came to the you know
started a start-up there was an option
for me to move to Stanford and finish up
with Michael Flynn dr. Flynn and Bob
really wanted that very but in the end I
copped out because I had to in that
point do a second qualifying exam at
Stanford which I thought was not a good
idea since I already passed that at
Illinois so that's my brief history and
then all we have a Stanford University
connection and all where at you I you
see University of Illinois
urbana-champaign when I started my
graduate studies there I have to say a
little bit about myself because I'm sure
95% of the people attending this talk
don't even know who the guy this is from
IBM so even though I'm a pretty old guy
so basically I thought I would mention
that this is the evolution of pretty
boss at IBM and so I started my iit
kharagpur my bachelor's and then joined
in university of illinois masters and
PhD and then my first project was this
risk superscalar project codenamed
cheetah and then America it's it's it's
now famous project mainly because of
john who i
work with and tillich agar wala you
probably don't know him
he was my also my hiring manager because
John didn't manage people he just worked
with people and many of you I don't know
if you had some of you seen senior
people in the audience have ever had the
opportunity to meet with John but he was
quite a person and I learned a lot from
him needless to say so that was the
first project and then there's a bunch
of other projects so 19a the next phase
was the launching of the power machines
because that started the start of the
power superscalar machines and that is
now in where we are doing power 10 now
so I've been associated with the power
family of processors ever since so there
was a period when we looked at the
system 390 also so I've been involved
with both power and the mainframe
processors system 390 vector facility
that was a very powerful and interesting
machine it has had a very sophisticated
vectorizing compiler I worked a little
bit on that and there was this period
also when the first wave of AI was upon
us I was having a discussion with about
with the students in the afternoon about
that first wave where part of it was
this expert system stuff where Stanford
University had a had a major
contribution through programs like
Meissen but IBM had a product called
expert systems systems architecture ESA
or something where it was a piece of
software they can write expert system
since I was part of that as well and
then the next phase came where we
designed power 3 I went to Austin on
assignment that was my product division
experience for three years so was the
chief performance architect for power 3
in the process designed and proposed mxu
which is a matrix unit which is a matrix
accelerator but didn't make it that's
why it's in red but power 3 did
I started also the culture of be VP's
performance verification programs
because by that time what happened was
we found that simulators architectural
simulators were could be quite wrong
so in predicting performance and so
performance verification of performance
modeling frameworks was an open item so
while at Austin and the product more I
started systematically systematizing the
process of generating pvp's so that you
gain confidence so that was now I can
since I started it now a set methodology
with an IBM which is good and then
started the high end you know gigahertz
domain regime processors with an IBM
power4 power 5
they also unfortunately made me a
manager at that time so ever since then
I have this management burden and which
you can see what happens you bend
backward again and with that burden and
we are back to this point so this
started the power aware
microarchitecture group we started
worrying about power as architects at a
time where where nobody was that
interested in power awareness but we
were seeing something from our modeling
that power would become a major
constraint nobody believed us at that
point but eventually I think it became
very clear and then later I added
reliability to our Charter because I
knew that power and reliability were
linked I'm going to talk about that a
little bit more and then we started
dynamic power management workload driven
power management not enough to design a
power efficient processor but he also
have to worry about the dynamic
properties of applications and how to
optimize the scheduling and the inner
workings of the processor power gating
and devfs how to make sure you manage
know how to power then we moved on to
other stuff with this is the beginning
of my adventure with DARPA and
fortunately we
they realized that if he remained just
in this mode it will be just worrying
about the short-term product development
cycle of IBM and there'll be no room to
think ahead about the future because by
this time what is beginning to happen
was the hardware systems market was
saturating and the industry as a whole
especially IBM was the beginning to turn
the ship to a different strategic route
where software and services was going to
dominate and in particular 2011 is when
the Jeopardy system was demonstrated the
AI and that started the AI the second
wave of AI at leas with an idea life
goes on and I think in the next phase of
my career at IBM I'll be again using the
DARPA funding to think ahead about our
systems there's this new paradigm called
swarm AI that I'm very interested in we
also are going to design the next
generation excess scale supercomputer so
by the way at IBM we do we do build
supercomputers blue-jean pql all these
machines and then the next one in the
one that you might have read about was
summit which was accepted you know there
was some press about the summit machine
and and then after that the Sierra
machine this so we built two machines
and at the coral one program and the
next supercomputer there exascale regime
computer is now do is going to be
happening after that right agile
hardware design flow and post CMOS
systems so in a nutshell robust AI HPC
and quantum computing are some of the
things that we are looking at for the
future rather long preamble but I think
that was important for you to understand
a little bit about who I am and this is
John this is Tillich I should also
acknowledge my BTech advisor some of you
know a professor P Das Gupta at IIT
Kharagpur but this was his dad
and he was my teacher at that point the
reason I never had this slide about IBM
research but I'll be very open we do not
get any students or graduates from
Stanford I am teaching Watson in recent
years so I wanted to do one slide of
cell selling but it's still the major
industry research lab it's strong its
vibrant we do exciting things and this
is our record it's not a not very bad
not too bad not too so just think about
us when you if you does those amongst
you who want to do research advanced
research meaningful research down down
to earth research at the same time we
think 2025 years ahead we do but we
still have to monitor thing about
monetization we don't do research in a
vacuum just for the sake of it I wish we
could actually we used to be able to do
that but we can't okay the next thing is
AI today everybody is doing AI even I
was this email came in this morning so I
put it in AI in the ITC international
test conference test week VLSI design
2019 team is autonomous intelligence for
safe secure smart world so it's not just
computer architects I could I could talk
about the architecture here conferences
which is where I go to not not
necessarily these ones but everybody is
into AI and so why not us so that's what
I'm going to next introduces this new
era of computing this is what has
happened I was mentioning this 2011
timeframe when this Jeopardy thing
happened Watson jeopardy before that
there was this rule-based expert systems
formalism and then you know that sort of
launched these to this sequence kind of
launched there was this deep blue chess
machine before that launched what we
call the cognitive system Sarah
for because AI became a bad word for a
number of decades after the first wave
kind of failed so IBM hesitated to use
the word hi now we are not saying
cognitive anymore we are being pretty
open saying it's this AI guys so this
this seems real so why is it happening
this time why now what is different this
time why do we think this is real this
time because of the timing you know the
data big data big data has happened is
lots of sensors out there lots of data
therefore opportunity for learning and
training and coming up with realistic
models that's one and then the computing
systems have evolved to the point where
things are possible so that in a
nutshell is is is what's happening as to
why this is happening now what about the
title of my departments name efficient
resilience what is efficient resilience
well system design approach to improve
efficiency with guarantees of
operational correctness in the late CMOS
era as as was introduced earlier we are
in the sort of era where Moore's law is
no longer working or sort of not working
as well we certainly don't talk about
Dennard scaling rule anymore Dennard is
from IBM by the way and you know by the
way I should mention that you know I've
worked 35 plus years at IBM but they're
not work 52 years and he still comes so
don't write me off yet I'm going to stay
there hopefully for famous last words
could be but I do plan to stay for a
while and do exciting stuff it's still
extremely wide vibrant if you vibrant
place yes yes I'm going to mention that
limitedly next so the point of this
chart of this cartoon is that the
powerwall and the reliability wall are
kind of limited and it's kind of like a
vicious circle because in order to
circumvent
the powerwall there's a tendency in
modern design to design with tighter
margins such as with you know lower
voltages or other other stringent
measures to safe power and then also
that results sometimes in higher maximum
temperature because you want to skimp on
packaging cost cooling cost you want the
cost is always important right and so
limited or no burnin again to save cost
for those of you are familiar with with
the term burnin what burning is an
interesting thing which has been done
for for for ages by at least by IBM all
the time is a fracture the chips are put
into there literally into an oven you
know like high very high temperature and
under very stressful conditions sort of
like a human being stepping onto a
stress machine worker you know when you
take a stress test similar concept and
if you are if you are a weak chip you'd
essentially die and then that's the way
to eliminate the weak chips and maybe 3%
5% of the chips fail and then the other
remaining 95% are strong deemed to be
strong enough and that you ship them
it's not just high voltage it's also
high there's no high temperature but
also high voltage right so you stress
out all the parameters as much as you
can within reason of course if you if
you do it too high everything will burn
so that's the science in itself how to
set the burning parameters and so that's
how you know the moment you do that
though other bad things sometimes happen
aging increases because you you age the
things faster and so you lose margin
because of that and so forth and so all
of that leads to us more stringent
reliability challenge reliability in
wall and then again in order to
circumvent that you try to put in more
stuff like parity ECC robust design
design adjustments redundancy all of
that what does it do adds more power so
back we go so this is the problem that
that we are facing in the late CMOS era
from a pureSystems nothing to do with AI
yet but in general this is the problem
right now cross layer design is
something that Professor Mitra helped us
a lot in the last DARPA project which is
over now using that principle we were
able to show I think that we were quite
successfully that you can you know solve
this problem and I'll have more things
to say about that later but this kind of
cross layer optimization is a key
enabler for mobile and real-time
computing which is the which is the
which is in my next chart to try to say
to me and to us many of us at IBM
Research this is really the new system
architectural vision for the cognitive
era of the AI era
what is that vision well you can't get
rid of the cloud the back-end cloud
that's ubiquitous it's there it's almost
invisible it's there when you use your
Apple phone it's there cloud is there
right but there's a whole bunch of these
mobile devices which are springing up
including of course the promise of
autonomic cars or auto self-driving cars
drones what-have-you right watches
robots you know even glasses smart
glasses and we envision the future as
being the following where all of these
devices will be communicating not just
with the back-end cloud as you have
today but also with each other why not
all the technology exists so why not
have think about a wireless ad-hoc
wireless network which these devices can
take advantage of case in point
just focus in on the self-driving car
market today if you look at the Google
car or any you know company's secret
project they are working with that
Google car model in mind very rich
sensors very expensive therefore
connected to the cloud but not talking
to each other this paradigm requires
fewer sensors therefore cheaper cars but
with the ability to talk to each other
and therefore forming what we call a
swarm cache of knowledge where if you
are in the need of getting so critical
piece of information from the cloud you
first try your neighbor first somebody
who might already have that information
so it is exactly in architects term like
a cache a local cache lower latency than
going to the cloud so this is our vision
of how the future interconnected IOT
cognitive IOT system architecture looks
like this we call swarm AI there are
many other connotations of this which
I'll get to gradually but some of the
things are listed here it can deal with
unstable or unreliable in a wireless
connectivity because of the redundancy
there's lots of these devices so one
fails you can always count on another it
has resilient system reconfiguration
capabilities so that's about resilience
- and then there are things that you can
you increasingly you can see happening
in each of these edge devices such as
approximation sampling filtering machine
learning acceleration so you can you can
see each of this progress of time these
smart devices being not just inference
engines but also doing edge based
training or learning and you can do that
better if you swarm with each other very
analogous to how us human beings we work
together not all of us know everything
we are domain experts in different
things but we know how to work together
and get a large project down I'm very
used to that in industry because
teamwork is very very critical and not
everybody has the same skills so this
there's a term in AI called transfer
knowledge which is related to this
concept which means if you get a device
which is trained in a particular domain
Candice
I learned something else a different
domain quickly rather than being
retrained in the factory with lots of
lots of new data there are other
implications here about cognitive
resilience which I'll get to later yes
no no that not but in this context I
meant could a supercomputer be used to
do back-end learning yes Karl Sims what
he was doing the 90s corporation Oh
quite different I think this is this is
as you will as I will hint I don't have
a full detailed disclosure in this in
this pitch but this is a paradigm this
is a new AI paradigm where you sort of
continuously learn in the field thinking
machines connection machines they were
architectural II you know machines which
could communicate with each other but
that's nothing to do with AI as we know
it today all right I mean it's a
philosophical debate of course with what
what is AI versus what is not but in
what when I mean AI here I mean you know
in a narrow sense machine learning deep
learning and that's the current state of
AI today if I what if I want to I don't
want to over generalize but simplifying
the way of where AI is today is machine
learning deep learning get trained with
lots and lots of data and then apply it
you know have that model in your brain
and then go solve day-to-day problems
right and there all sorts of learning
networks but in a nutshell is that right
that's why this has happened as I was
mentioning in that previous slide this
is why is the sudden in the last five
years this has happened because of
availability of lots and lots of data
and increase in processing power no
other reason because neural networks is
not a new field it's been there for 50
years
right it's just that the time was it was
before its time
now it's enabled by big data 70 years
okay I won't argue so there are these
needs that we will examine at the edge
the important point for us is what do
each of these processes at the edge have
to look like how do you have to how do
we design these embedded devices or
processes at the edge to be able to
function in this futuristic world and
it's not that futuristic every auto
company that you're talking to have in
this Toyota right here
Toyota research in which we are plugged
in with they have a project called
collaborative perception so we call it
swarm AI they have a secret project
called not-so-secret they publish papers
so it's an open thing it's not
proprietary anything they openly
presented it to us right so it says you
know in people are inevitably going to
think about this so every other company
has is thinking something like this I
believe the timing may not be right yet
for us to jump straight into this but
that's because the research is not done
okay so from swarm intelligence swarm
intelligence as a term is not new either
it's a bio-inspired algorithm which is
used primarily for optimization such as
ant colony optimization and particle
swarm optimization but it's an
optimization technique where is
analogous to simulated annealing
so bio-inspired but that was the limit
of what swarm intelligence was from
swarm intelligence we want to go to
adaptive swarm intelligence which is
what we are doing where the whole scope
is to fix the cognitive resilience issue
that the fact that these algorithms tend
to be brittle because what happens is
that you train it with lots and lots of
data and then in the field sometimes
surprise
changes of data patterns happen as a
result the accuracy performance liquid
equals accuracy classification or
inference accuracy plummets whoops
plummets precipitously and then in these
brittle systems they don't recover
anymore because it doesn't know the new
data other than sending the device back
to the factory to get retrained there's
no solution today so big open problem in
modern AI is how to fix this so that it
might take this is the desired solution
these are all cartoons that it plummets
the accuracy plummets for a short while
but it picks right back up and goes
along this is what we want continuous
learning in the field we believe and
there's a DARPA program in which we are
not part of that is tackling this power
Siegelman is a program manager we
believe that the adaptive swarm
intelligence concept where these these
sort of what's adaptive about it there's
a new word AI param that inspired by
swarm intelligence principles but
enables a level of cognition that can
emerge synergistically from the swamp
but not from individual devices alone so
each of these devices may be pretty dumb
in itself but the swarming helps each of
its brains each of his learning engines
to evolve over time to gain from each
other's knowledge silly example suppose
a car in California here not used to New
York's no getting used to
autonomic driving here autonomous
driving is sent to New York it might not
have been trained with the right data to
function properly in the snow and ice of
New York so what does it do you send it
back to the factory to get trained or do
you get it
trained ideally would like like it to
learn quickly from its New York brothers
and sisters
right so that's the promise I'm not
saying that this is this is the this is
the this this is one of the examples of
motivations so there is a resilience
Atlas what my point of that was oh by
the way this is a broad paradigm we
believe it's not just limited to
autonomous cars but it can apply to
things like cyber security you know
cyber security network cyber security
where a number of different agents
sitting listening in on the on the
network could cooperate with each other
in determining quickly that it's under
attack it could apply more generally to
unmanned aerial vehicles it's almost the
same as this except it's a much more
complex problem because there are more
degrees of motion search-and-rescue
operations using smart drone swamps in
the mid there obvious miniature military
connotations in each of these as well
but I'm focusing on the civilian or
examples distributed power management
this is something that we are
immediately doing for our next
generation processors and data centers
so this is what we do we get the
research we do it we get the money to
perform them and then we try to apply it
as what as immediately as possible to
something real so we'll talk about this
a little bit if there's time
so edge embedded SOC trends see of
accelerators you all know this now I'm
going to spend too much time the
challenges are so a bunch of different
CPU general purpose course GPUs maybe a
bunch of different accelerators memories
a question is how what's the design
integration this is this is this is
apart from this is in addition to the
application level trends this is in
general a problem how do you take an
application domain and quickly
synthesize a system not just a chip a
system on a chip but a software stack to
make it programmable because it's no
good to have us just an automated push
in methodology which gives you a chip
you want to be wanted to be programmable
that's in a nutshell what the DARPA er
ID sock domain-specific SOC program is
with Tom Rando being the program manager
and that's what we wanted the current
DARPA program which has just been
launched started working on yes yes sure
we'll get to it right away because even
in this tank picture you know that I
painted before if you take autonomous
cars according to Vedas is defined it
roughly covers two domains computer
vision and software radio why is that
computer vision is obvious these are
intelligent cars have cameras and you
have to process videos so you have to
recognize obstacles stop signs yield
signs lane markers all many smart cars
all of our smart cars today have Lane
lane violation signals already write
some rudimentary things are already
happening but this is more than that is
being able to avoid obstacles avoid
pedestrians there are many by the way
since you bring this up might as well
say it now many ethical issues if you
have a choice of hitting a pedestrian
versus a tree you want to make sure that
you hit a tree not the pedestrian how do
you teach a machine to do that these
will come up so ethical issues ethical
issues in cognitive machines is an
emerging new topic right and so why is
the software radio part a domain in
there because you have to have wireless
connectivity and you are dealing with
radar and and radio frequency
communication so therefore
software-defined radio is a domain right
okay so that's an example you could have
just you can just focus on computer
vision and actually professor mark
Horowitz is also doing this program API
and this program is focusing only on
computer vision I'll talk I'll talk to
that in a second
but going back to this this is this is
the strategic alignment with systems
this is not just about the edges my
point of this graph it's also about the
cloud the systems that I talked about
why because this is very important in
the post more post Dennard era it is
highly possible is it not somebody
mentioned that the GF announcement about
seven nanometer it is highly possible
that the whole cadence the two-year
cadence the tick-tock is not going to
happen anymore right it's going to
become three years four years maybe in
six years maybe eight years before you
ship on your system how does the IT
industry then survive because the whole
point was that I think and this is just
my view not not IBM's not darvis is that
the way to keep this market sustained is
to yes accept the fact that your cadence
is increasing but meanwhile you supply
you know coherence coherent accelerator
interfaces you give them an accelerator
domain-specific accelerator every six
months so you install your shift system
you learn your particular customers who
are clothes and if you have an agile
methodology which is the point about
this sock you with a very small team has
to be a small team has to be a small
thing ten people 15 people deliver a
custom accelerator or set of
accelerators for the customer to choose
from right having having learned their
customer profile this could be the new
business model yes this is it
there's no I'm not asking for a new fad
node every six months am I
I'm saying understand your customers
workloads and give them appropriate
accelerators to which must be pluggable
[Music]
keeping your customer doing very
practical keeping your customer happy
for six years instead of two years or
eight years and if you say that you're
funky and you should be able to measure
that performance otherwise it's no point
I mean instead of shipping a new thing
which is saying I'm going to give you a
new system this is old-style right which
is 2x the performance every two years
right that was all that's gone on it's
not possible
look at this what what we're saying in
this curve this is from Stanford this is
John Hennessey's curve so it has to
right so this is what there's no there's
room right I mean so this this is this
is this is one way I'm just proposing
this this is my hypothesis yes it has to
be a bunch of consumers with similar
application characteristics I'm dividing
it suppose you sell to a hundred
thousand customers not I'm not
this is server business so it's not
millions it's not a cell phone market
pating the case for the case for this
mobile market I already made this is
obvious this is where but this is I'm
saying even for the server mainframe
market this is relevant because even if
it's a hundred thousand customers you've
clustered them into groups because there
are many commonalities airline companies
American Airlines Continental whatever
our customers these are all IBM
customers who buy from us even though
so you study them and give them a
solution every six months so it
amortizes I think I think it does if
it's if your net customers base is two
then yeah it won't work but it has to be
something substantial 100,000 at least
then it does work and by the way you you
look at from a customer's point of view
instead of upgrading to a brand new
system which is going to cost them a
million dollars if it's an IBM mainframe
you give them something every six months
which is fifty thousand dollars I think
it's a good deal so I'm just I'm not a
business person I'm a technical person
but I see this very clearly this is that
what's going to happen and so therefore
working on projects like this arc is
strategically important for even a
completely IBM so whether it's the edge
or the cloud this kind of agile
methodology of translating an
application domain understanding your
customer workload and synthesizing it
down to an accelerator which you can
plug in it's a good business case when I
present at this point of view to one of
the key AI VP's recently he said you've
got a potential game changer I support
you 110% so I think I got my answer so
anyway these are the D socks selected
participants and yes professor mark
Horowitz is one of the winners he's
focusing computer vision the Arizona
State University it's a big project with
lots of universities and industries
focusing on software-defined radio Oak
Ridge National Labs focusing on
software-defined radio we had only ones
who are focusing on two different
domains and trying to understand the
fundamentals of the problem and to come
up with a solution focusing as a driving
application the autonomous self-driving
car which is arguably an interesting hot
area
which is easy for us to get excited
about and the researchers assigned to it
and DARPA I think Tom Rondo likes this
application a lot now this is again to
say again more assertively that this is
the application domain we are focusing
on autonomous vehicles and the project
name is epochs efficient programmability
of cognitive heterogeneous systems and
this is a cartoon about how the car
autonomous car business is increasing
already a number of companies investing
into autonomous cars and and and I think
this is this is a focus on intelligent
connected autonomous vehicles with
computer vision and software radio those
are the two application domains right
and more details this is how the
application kind of looked like the
effluence the first one the first tasks
that we are committed to which we have
made very good progress to the point
where this application the first version
is already available open source on
github right if you're interested I can
point you to it
because we could we can use all the
collaborative in the whole purpose of
open source software as well as hardware
is to is to amortize the cost and get to
lower cost design things software and
hardware with fewer people so it has in
the version that we have we are focusing
on right now on the radar and the DSRC
this is the short range communications
kind of digital digital short range
communication module and link to the you
know millimeter wave radar and imaging
real-time consensus and fusion so Fusion
is a very big part if you have
multimodal input coming and streaming
through how do you make sense of the two
diverse heterogeneous kinds of inputs
and and and come to a consensus about
what you're seeing first shadows
as I was saying sensor fusion sensor
fusion is an important part of this
cooperative sensor fusion and you can
apply the principle of swamp
intelligence here because on your own
you may be confused you're getting the
camera and the associated intelligence
saying this is a stop sign
but the other sensor may be leading you
to believe you might be dealing with a
yield sign silly example but I'm just
saying is you know it could be issues
right or pedestrian versus a tree and so
this is where the swamp helps because
other cars are seeing the same thing but
from a different vantage angle and they
may have a richer view in some cases no
no so if they supply you with that maybe
you can fuse things together and come up
with a crisper classification so
individually another way in AI terms is
that your own inference engine on its
own may be at eighty nine percent
accuracy but when you make use of
collaborative input from other agents of
your kind you may be able to increase
your classification accuracy to 95% 99%
it's like crowdsourcing guys what do you
do when you want an answer how many
calories is this hamburger this program
exists as app crowdsourcing gives you
know you can apply this people have
demonstrated this even with human beings
same principle anyway so this is more
details on how the ER a application is
constructed and we are using this Ross
framework to put everything together
that's the first version I'm not going
to go into too many details on this one
but except focusing on the hardware
right now this is optimized hardware for
embedded AI now you can see there's a
footnote here saying note that the
difference different that this is not so
different
from this from the specs of a modern
high-performance supercomputer because
the individual note there also
interestingly enough has to be extremely
low-power otherwise you don't get to
build this entire excess skin
supercomputer with only a 30 megawatt
power limit you just can't do the math
and so you need to focus on how to build
resilient low-power devices for a whole
spectrum of processes from embedded all
the way to cloud as well as
supercomputing large-scale
supercomputing resilience is probably
even more important than efficiency for
a supercomputer why because the number
of processors is thousands so the fit
rate is not small enough your mean time
to failure can be seconds or minutes
easy math reliability 101 so therefore
you can see that focusing on just the
embedded domain evidently you might say
why are you working on embedded
processors because iBM is not going to
do and but but no you need a driving
motivation or application an exciting
one but the technology that comes out of
it applies pervasively
to even your core business right so
that's that's good
other point is that today's cars are
moving data centers with onboard sensors
and computers that capture rhythm this
is this is taken from the IBM web page
and Watson applied to IOT so there is
actually an IOT automotive division of
Watson so we do take this domain very
seriously how we offer the solutions is
actually a new business opportunity that
I would like to create in an
entrepreneurial mode you would like our
research team to actually like years ago
we went we did this some of us in
entering the game market believe it or
not at some point all the game processes
were from IBM the Sony Xbox the Nintendo
as well as Apple
right all the game processors were from
IBM we had to move out from that because
we couldn't deliver the the low power
because we really want to cater to our
high performance high power that is our
bread and butter right but if you could
develop technology which does high
performance and energy efficiency
together low power as well as high
performance then that would be very good
for us applies to edge applies to basic
fundamental technology to servers so
this term called wide operating range
profit
processors refers to what I say
something that is designed to operate
across a range of voltage frequencies
not just one volt and you know 4
gigahertz which is our high-end server
design point approximately these systems
are actually higher frequency like 6 but
we want the same processor to be operate
quite efficiently all the way down to
0.5 0.4 maybe even 0.3 why not
so if you combine low voltage technology
with specialized acceleration then you
have it then you can get two levels of
performance for what whatever metric you
want to use if you're in the AI domain
then you would use the term nano joules
per prediction and a joules per
inference that's throughput performance
per watt if for your domain you can get
to that remember years ago the first
heterogeneous commercial processor was
from IBM this was the Cell processor
which powered game systems from Sony and
others at the same time it powered
supercomputers it was the number one on
the supercomputing list the same
processor same concept wide operating
range except that we didn't know how to
go to really low voltages today there's
a need to go to really low voltages also
and that's a lot of this we did work on
the
the DARPA perfect project so here is a
sampling of the chips that we put out
under the DARPA perfect project
surprisingly and nicely all of the chips
that we have taped out work these are
from Harvard and this is from IBM and
this is from IBM and you know Virginia
together a lot of test chips before that
one of the key things here is how to
make s ramps work at really low voltages
because if those of you with circus
background know that that the
fundamental reasons you can't go to very
low voltages that there's ramps don't
work
so naturally we focused a lot of
research and test chips that showed how
to make s s ramps work at as low as 0.25
volts and for us so that's what has gone
into these processors and this one is
just back from the fab and initial tests
are showing that it works which is good
we should be able to get the full
analysis done soon so that we submit it
somewhere and this is not yet back from
the fab
yes SRAM's
does that hurt there or latency there
our equation there are curves that we
can we can show later but yes it's not
that hard to compute right within that
range roughly voltage and frequency are
linear so if you go down from what is
your starting point one volt to 0.3
volts
you get frequency you know hit of that
same ratio approximately yes but the
whole concept is about throughput
performance so if you have lots of
little course with low voltage then and
if your application many ifs is lot of
parallelism in it then you can't lose
with that throughput proof of
performance before throughput per what
will be very high using that paradigm
this is well known so I didn't devote a
slide to that it's obvious if you have a
small serial component Yoram dolts
component is small if you have lots of
parallelism then going to low-voltage
and many of these applications are like
that when you offload to the accelerator
is embarrassingly parallel after all the
heart of this deep learning machine
learning thing is matrix multiplication
and vector stuff which is embarrassingly
parallel so yes going to low voltage and
frequency helps we should have lots of
discourse so this can be a GPU yes this
discussion came up so this is the
paradigm to beat a GPU and but but of
course the GPU of whom if we try to make
it at lower voltage it would benefit to
and we have tried that also in the
course of this research and I think I
have a slide
this is tools that came out of the
perfect thing and again I wanted to just
show that so that you know the
contribution of the Stanford team under
Professor Mitra is highlighted the cross
let the clear methodologies at least
professor Mitra students know about this
very well but the basic concept of how
to optimize voltage for a given
application is an interesting one
because again SRAM's is you know stop
working after a while so how do you you
know how do you design the optimal
voltage may be can you can you even go
there's a circuit women but can you go
even below by exploiting what we call
application level resilience okay this
is this is this is something we you
wouldn't I wouldn't try it on my bank
software but for image processing
intensive applications where bit flips
don't mean as much we actually tried
this and to see even if some amount of
des Ram bits are flipping because of
lower voltage low voltage errors does it
affect the ultimately end edge
classification and the answer is
surprisingly but maybe not so
surprisingly that has a large amount of
Tolerance you can go down even below
this
circuit women of 0.3 volts or whatever
you came up with yes not control but
suppose I'll give you a simple example
this is the chip that we build I mean
you're going to talk to this a couple of
slides I know we're at the end of this
my time though so I have to finish up
real fast but let me just go to that so
let me just spend a minute here to
explain the chips that we built from
Harvard and this they also exploited
application level resilience to get to
this level of efficiency but they didn't
use low voltage s ramps they relied
completely on application level
resilience to get to the level of you
know efficiency that they could
demonstrate for us before while we were
taping out the chips we also did a
project in an aggressive under bolting
of GPUs NVIDIA GPUs as they currently
stand there's a big opportunity we
showed 20% lower voltage I also wanted
to highlight this complex voltage
control loops that we already did I was
part of the team which did this complex
control flow to do adaptive guard
bending which means essentially
operating near the edge so that only
occasionally when you're when you're on
the edge you have these cannery circuits
which tell you and then you do something
like throttle your frequency that's the
basic concept lots this is actually
shipped in real products power7 as way
back as power7 but we try to apply a
different set of techniques in our test
chips and in for the GPU case we can't
control the GPU because it's from Nvidia
we do use NVIDIA GPUs in our systems as
as you know but we we have talked to
them often about you know the
opportunity that they're leaving on the
table in terms of efficiency let's see
where this goes but we did extensive
experiments with commercial GPUs lots of
them not just one board to come up with
date
which shows that you could do aggressive
under volting yes there was a point
where beyond which you get silent data
corruption and you get kuda runtime
error SiC fault but there's a large you
know you can you can you can do things
like you know go beyond the circuit
women and we even proposed a counter
based methodology of predicting the
onset of a voltage droop which is an
interesting thing you can predict that
this voltage droop is going to happen
and so predictably try to raise your
frequency your voltage or lower your
frequency to cope with that similar to
the cannery circuits that we had in
power seven but this is a completely
different digital kind of means to Drake
that okay so the concept is the same now
I'm going to skip this in the interest
of time but we did with this kind of a
statistical modeling of errors in memory
we did fault injection experiments for
classical neural network kind of
artificial neural network topologies of
various kinds to understand the limits
of resilience of these applications I'll
just leave it at that
and then some of that thinking went into
this chip which was taped out on his
back and it's working I was mentioning
called Dante
we used the boosted SRAM technology from
dr. Rajiv Joshi in our team and his and
his team to get to really low voltage
SRAM's
and this is in this case 60s SRAM even
commercial easily available 60s SRAM
with all the fabs having compilers for
60s Ram we added the boost circuitry
manually of course there's thought of
packaging this up as an elaborate 4gf if
they are interested of course they may
not be anymore
but but then this chip was taped out and
we have a working chip but we don't have
the full results yet it should come in a
month or two these are this is some
sampling of the results that we already
have this is applying em nest
versus this Alex net and showing the
energy performance trade-offs
performance here means accuracy so you
can obviously as you go to higher
voltages get to higher levels of
accuracy but even if you dropped the
voltage but you add the selectively
boosting of s ramps those are different
voltage levels of the boost you can then
stick to a very low supply voltage and
still get to very high levels of
classification accuracy so that's what
the measurements are showing and so we
are very happy about that now quickly
wrap up I promise in five minutes I'm
sorry for extending but this is I have
to say a few things about D sock and so
nutshell these are the core key focus
areas so one of them as you can see is
this interesting ontology thing which
dr. Rondo the program manager really
likes as part of his program this what
this means is that and this just should
appeal to the design automation
community in general given an
application is there science a
systematic way in which you can argue
these are the right primitives for which
you should build accelerators in a
nutshell that's the problem in some
sense and it's not just one application
of course it's a number of applications
representing a domain so if you're
saying computer vision it's not one
application program it's several and you
have to analyze that and say what are
the right primitives which cover so see
I used the term cover it's a covering
problem what's the right set of
primitives and all of you working in
design automation know then the famous
the covering problem this is a this is a
place of dr. McCluskey right Quinn
McCluskey algorithm right so covering
problem how to use the prime implicants
to cover a function same problem here
except you have to do it solve it never
been done before so that's what this
team is working on coupled with the
compiler because the compiler has to be
in the loop this is open source compiler
and programming model this is
the Illinois contribution to the project
is the open source compiler which is
LLVM yes but now that they have new
abstraction called HPV my pipe sorry
heterogeneous parallel virtual machine
and so it's able to generate graphs as
an intermediate representation as
opposed to a linear IR as in LLVM and
then you can process that to do anta
logical analysis etc right so the
compiler is in the loop from the get-go
to try to solve this ontological problem
then this agile design flow IBM and
Columbia and Harvard are in it together
and then there's an interesting
distributed swarm resource management so
this whole principle of swarm AI we
don't want it to apply just to the
larger system level but also to the chip
how to manage power in a distributed
manner with lots of course you know
instead of having a centralized resource
so let me just skip these Hardware
things for a minute and focus on that is
the last couple of slides saying
distributed power management how do you
do distributed power management for many
core processor associ so previous design
today's designs both Intel IBM MD all of
them have an on-chip power manager which
is a centralized bottlenecks resource it
does not scale as you go to the many
core paradigm that's not going to scale
it's going to be the performance
bottleneck because you have to do sense
and actuate and if you have many number
of course you that latency is so much
that your performance suffers becomes
the gate so you need to distribute this
this is obvious now how do you
distribute that we are trying an
aggressive approaching extreme total
distribution no centralized resource
involved hardware so these cores
talk to each other exchange power
information and applications and power
state information and collaboratively
distribute power tokens fixed number of
tokens because if a fixed power budget
100 tokens let us say how do you
distribute this how 100
within yourselves to be able to maximize
what's the objective function throughput
of course within a car borrow power
budget how do you maximize support and
therefore throughput for what so that's
the thing that we implemented I'm not
going to go into details of the
algorithm but you know visually this is
one cartoon to show that it works is a
simulation that basically what it means
is that this is power tokens as fixed
number of power tokens this is without
any distributed power manager enabled
this is with the distributed power
manager enabled and you know basically
the darker colors mean that there there
are these short token shortfalls where
some somebody is starving because you
you took away too many power tokens as a
result of this game
whereas this distributed algorithm that
we have shows a much better picture
where because if you have shortfall of
tokens that means your performances
throttled so your throughput across this
course is starved and so this is just a
didn't have time to go through the exact
algorithm there was a chart on that but
in summary I do need to finish these
messages that the need for SOC
specialization is increasing but costs
are prohibitive and increasing as well a
new approach is to realizing novel
heterogeneous architectures is needed
programmability efficiency modularity
scalability are the key system design
focus areas for us in this project
energy efficiency under resilience
constraints always comes up in these
situations because you need to make it
work first and then argue about energy
efficiency so that's a constraint and
this is where leveraging our DARPA
perfect program artifacts is going to
help us the efox goal is to improve
cognitive IOT efficiency at the edge by
100x within five to seven years
the super domain that we have chosen for
us is intelligent communicating
autonomous vehicles which is a
combination of two domains computer
vision and software-defined radio key
innovation areas I talked about the
decentralized Hardware control assist to
support intelligent Oster I didn't talk
about the OS task scheduler but moment
you have this distributed swamp our
manager in the hardware it needs to be
supported by a smart operating system
task scheduler which knows how to
schedule with this thing underneath
right and so that's what that is and
then retarget able adaptive compiler
talked about this briefly formalism for
workload analysis the ontological
framework to figure out the right
accelerators to build there's also I
didn't talk about but coherent shared
memory support to ease program ability
for these heterogeneous chips of the
future I talked about I didn't talk
about gal's
mac layer but there that is one of the
things with autonomous resource power
management design ecosystem supporting
wide operating range talked about that a
little bit the concept wise
heterogeneous SOC is scalable from 25
Watts down to 5 watts that's what the
wide operating range functionality buys
you this is a DARPA manded at 25 watts
to 5 what these are numbers given by
DARPA open source agile hardware design
flow for e for quick system synthesis I
mentioned the motivation for our point
of view for doing that that if you can
supply accelerators to your customer
base quickly with small teams that's
going to be the new business model
according to me leverages prior IP
library very low voltage SRAM and
associate a DNN accelerators developed
under the DARPA perfect so we already
have a rich library of I piece created
so this really supports the agile flow
and you know that we are after because
we don't have to design things from
scratch there's a whole library of open
source hardware that we have created so
with that I'm ready to take any
questions if the chairman allows
[Music]
challenges and solution strategies for
this swarm the ad hoc network with
unreliable wireless things etc good
question we don't I wish I had the
answer to everything yet but this is why
we have just started but this is a I
gave you a concept pitch but let me say
the following we have years and years of
experience with building resilient
mainframe and server processors right in
a multi-core setting we know when a core
fails unknown to the user how that core
state is transplanted from one court to
another core in the system without the
user batting an eyelid knowing knowing
what happened we have perfected that for
the last 20 25 years so chance this is
to me similar if something is unreliable
goes down whatever we have a way of
doing cooperative computation in that
and one we know how to do that using
software and hardware so that's my brief
answer of my first idea on how to do
that yes
any other question I might try this is
Stanford University I mean I I don't
think I can deal with all of your
brightness it's awesome but yes there's
a starting but that's an interesting
thought but what companies are banking
on is you know these cameras that are
ubiquitous yeah everywhere doesn't have
to be trees let you know posts they can
form part of the input right so so they
are there and they are already being
used many of these IP towers cell phone
towers are used for programs like Waze
if you think about ways by the way
that's the collaborative swamp thing
where the human beings are inputting
data so that other people other users
benefit so if in some sense I'm trying
to automate that so I think I think
there's a proof point that it works how
many people in the room we use ways I
use so this is a smart GPS algorithm
compared to I mean and if you think
about its collaborative perception or
Swami I if I want to use a buzzword but
it's a it's about collaboratively
computing in an altruistic manner to
help everybody yes efficiencies are nice
we are faced with a horrendous software
problem we are now going to construct
the most complex software that has ever
been attended what could possibly go
[Laughter]
interesting thought point so there was a
project within IBM which I supported
very strongly coming out of our indus in
india research lab you just talk about
dynamic load detection and reduction
interesting concept where it's
recognizing that due to years and years
of software bloat where software
developers have taken advantage of very
fast hardware that we engineers have
produced have been very lacks in
software I hope I'm not offending some
software people here but the question is
can some some of these extra transistors
which might still be available but not
how to use them to do things like
dynamic load detection software to try
to not do unnecessary computation yes
[Music]
decide well programmers for the number
of lines of code right
humor me for one minute one more minute
because I want to share with you this
philosophical future research mission oh
so why should you Adam I don't want to
tell you the secret thing that I want to
spill the beans a little bit that I
think I was discussing this with some of
the students we need to go beyond AI as
we know it we need to look at what
consciousness is and see if we can build
self-aware systems truly thinking
machines not of them not just saying
thinking machines but something with a
machine which can recognize so what is
the hard problem of consciousness for
those of you philosophers amongst you
it's the hard problem is how does a
machine like this have this first person
subjective experience where I can say I
predict pose
I where is this I coming from how's this
I feeling generated that's the problem I
think is is is waiting for computer
scientists AI scientist neuromorphic
scientists to try to finally grapple yes
very good question I was hoping you
would ask that question why do you think
it is important I hope I'll give you my
answer I was mentioning peripherally
there's these ethical questions it's
given a pedestrian versus a tree which
do I hit I don't want this to be
programmed artificially I want this for
a system to figure out automatically
saying obviously I hit the tree so
ethical issues this is a big subject if
you google ethics and cognitive
computing or AI computing is a big but
but there is this fundamental principle
of course and that's where this cloud
thing is very important how you program
this cloud because you have to use that
judiciously this is the ubiquitous kind
of cloud which is in some sense
projecting this this universe of suam
agents so if this becomes extremely
important which I like because I work
for IBM and the cloud is important so
this is becomes a very important piece
of how you program that but you don't
have to worry so much about how these
are programmed because this this are
very dependent on that so continuous
learning happens because the latest
knowledge gets pushed down here
periodically and to keep things clean
right so that's the new model that I
have in mind where you know if think of
it this way this is this is this is this
wireless network has all the knowledge
in it here in the swarm cache as well as
through this you know cloud to swarm
connectivity there's a lot of
information hopefully good information
and so these are just receivers
think of it as radios in a universe
where there are lots of radio waves and
if I can make the radio be more human
like self-aware then it can do better
things with the information which is
already there yes I have to take pains
to make sure that that information is
not tainted yes there are security
issues and there but but if I can
safeguard that then now have created a
world where this game of self-aware
conscious call it artificial
consciousness if you like I'm super AI
if you like but you really have to go
beyond what we normally called AI anyway
that's that's
you